it could be said that the St Louis
archbishops smelled blood in the water a
couple of weeks ago as they competed in
the semifinal round of the 2014 US chess
League playoff there were no draw odds
in this occasion in fact if the match
went 2 to2 The tiebreak Gauntlet would
be enacted that's exactly what happened
St Louis was successful on the first two
boards as Wesley so defeated Julio
Basera and Quang Lim defeated renier
Gonzalez so far the lineup that we have
now for the playoffs is what is working
but um we also have bir serve
Grandmasters like GM B and fold who is
always here giving moral support thank
you very much and also V voban who's
always um there just in case we we need
him but yeah Spence Spencer fold and
Matt lson are great players they are um
masters of their own kind and I'd say
that Matt Larson is kind of underrated
right now so it's a good thing for the
team just to make it to the average
rating St Louis couldn't clinch on the
bottom two boards as boards three and
four Matt Larsson and Spencer fold
respectively lost to National Masters
feder Rico Gonzalez and Carlos gastone
Andrea yeah I think I made a mistake
early and then he had a lot of pressure
and I don't know I never figured out how
to equalize and diffuse the pressure and
just went downhill from there the format
for the tiebreaker was a gauntlet style
elimination one Blitz game at a time
starting with both teams board four
players I don't know if the format's
really really fair to but I think it
benefits our team with our very strong
players so I can't complain the Sharks
board four player Carlos Andrea proved
very difficult for the St Louis team at
first he checkmated Spencer fold and
then had an excellent performance
against Matthew lson St Louis only had
two players left to the Sharks four
Quang Lee stepped up to the plate and
showed why he is a Grandmaster Quang Le
defeated Carlos Andrea rendering the
score back closer 2 to3 Quang Le even
the score after defeating federo
Gonzalez now only the top two board
players from both teams remained Quang
leim took White against the Miami sharks
renier Gonzalez with a draw both players
are eliminated and so Wesley so of St
Louis took black against Grandmaster
Julio Basera of the Sharks board one
versus Board One Wesley so got the
victory the sole survivor to get us
through to the final round where we meet
the Dallas Destiny and when we meet
Dallas St Louis will use a slightly
modified version of their playoff roster
that has been so successful board one
will still be Grandmaster Wesley so
board to Grandmas baruan niobian
National Masters Matthew lson and
Spencer fold will round out the field on
boards three and four their opponents on
the Dallas Destiny are captained by
Grandmaster Conrad h on Board number one
boards 2 through 4 include International
Master Jeffrey Jeong and National
Masters Francisco Guadalupe II and caric
ramachandran be sure to catch the games
on the internet chess club the action
begins at 7:20 p.m. central Time the
archbishops own Ben fold and Jacob
Wilkins will have the call as we stream
commentary live here from the St Louis
chess club at St Louis chess club.org
h